I'm Brendan Fraser I'm here with Sadie
sink and Darren Aronofsky and we're
going to break down a scene from the
whale
the well is about a lot of things and
one thing it's about is forgiveness and
hope and human connection and Brendan's
character Charlie in this scene is
trying to kind of reconnect with his
daughter who is very hurt and very angry
with him and so uh he's slowly trying to
find a way in to connect her and I think
this is the first time maybe in the
movie when
um he reaches his daughter just a little
bit
[Applause]
foreign
she did not want me around you
hoped that she would change her mind
eventually but she could have just
[ __ ] called me
when we first Meet Ellie and see her
with Charlie in the film this is the
first time they're together in 10 years
I think
um he had left her when she was eight
years old
um because he fell in love with someone
else so left her and her mother Ellie at
this point has a lot of pent-up rage and
anger
um towards her father but it's really
just coming from that sense of pain that
she's in she was really hurt by him and
betrayed by him
all this timing
could have been a part of my life
really
you know you really follow the text
to inspire the blocking and the
performances of the characters and we
were really blessed to have three and a
half weeks of rehearsal time where
basically all the actors myself and Sam
Hunt are the writer came together and uh
worked on the blocking and worked on the
performances
it kind of made sense uh for uh Sadie's
character Ellie to be hiding from her
father she didn't want to look at him
she was upset she was hiding from him
she was disgusted by him she was so many
different feelings and it was Charlie's
job to slowly kind of eke it out of her
and that's kind of what the blocking
reveals the blocking also reveals that
Charlie's just recently become a little
bit more mobile because Liz his his
friend and his caregiver has
appropriated him a wheelchair his
Mobility is
limited to really the couch or his bed
and
so in the scene he's actually physically
able to get a little bit closer to her a
little bit closer to her whereas before
if he even tried to take to his feet he
would he would have fallen to the ground
and
even to the point where he's able to
rotate her in her chair so that they can
speak to one another and it's the first
time she doesn't Bolt from him
hoped that she would change her mind
the way I see it is that he's always
been the positive person
that he is given that likely all his
life he's just been called names and
scorned and derided to the point where
he had to make a decision about whether
to live in a cynical world or to survive
by
internalizing it and having a positive
outlook you know I thought a little bit
about that
Brandon and today uh discussions and
stuff and I I wonder do you think that
Charlie was dishonest for the for the
his whole life or is this a turning
point that he's making right now
uh in this and I I don't know I wish Sam
was here to answer
I'm gonna guess that it's because his
nature as an educator and um he would
have always been seeking this out from
his students wanting to get through and
I think he probably took that on board
knowing his limited amount of time what
the stakes are concerning him being able
to
not connect with her that I think he
better practice what he preaches
eventually but
she called me
all this timing
you could have been a part of my life
well I I love this scene because I think
this was the first time you really got
to see that sincere side of her and and
the side of her that's really hurt and
then Charlie has this line at the end
after she kind of expresses like you
could have called you could have reached
out you you could have been sending more
money besides child support he says what
was that line he goes look at me look at
me who would want me to be a part of
their lives and I think
that for Ellie that's not a sad thing
that he just said I think that angers
her it's like I think it's a cop-out for
her like what do you mean who doesn't
who wouldn't want their father to be a
part of their lives I think
and then obviously in the next scene she
she does something pretty aggressive
really that's interesting because I and
I think that's kind of I think that's
what what triggers it because how could
you say something like that you know I'm
I'm your daughter
look at me
who would want me to be a part of their
life
[Music]
it's one of my favorite moments of
Sadie's in the movie how she plays that
it's just just this beautiful moment
where
she kind of knows I I don't know exactly
what Sadie was doing completely and
that's why it's a great performance but
it's totally great which is
she knows she's going to look at him the
audience knows she's going to look at
him but she really takes her time to
look at him because of everything that's
going on in her head because she's
thinking about she's kind of a head her
character is so wickedly smart that
she's ahead of pretty much everything
that's kind of going on she's she's
never really surprised she's kind of two
or three lines ahead of the script and
almost every scene except for maybe the
end
um and the only time she's really in the
moment is for the very last her very
last line of the scene of the movie and
the last line of the movie she's finally
in the moment with him but the rest of
the time she's just racing ahead of
everyone
um and even in this scene which is like
a deep emotional connection
um she doesn't want to give him that
moment she just is going to like she's
resisting it but she knows she has to
listen to him because he's asking for
something that's really truthful
who would want me to be a part of their
life
I think he has no other play I don't
think Stitch's only move
is to lay himself completely bare he
knows how hurt she is and he knows that
anything he tries to say to get through
to her to show her how he feels is
really going to fall on deaf ears
because she has very little sympathy for
him
so I think he's just speaking but he
believes her to be the belief of also I
love it I mean what what I love about
Sam's writing is exactly this type of
conversation it's so rich and it allows
for the performers to play things in
such complicated ambiguous uh ways I
just know that the whale is going to be
performed around the world for the rest
of our lives because the writing is so
rich and so many actors are going to
have fun playing it one thing that was
interesting that I remembered is right
before I Shot the movie I went back to
see a recording of the um play that I
hadn't seen for 10 years and the actors
all played it completely differently I
mean most notably
um Charlie was played by an actor who
was kind of more Gruff and grouchy and a
lot more anger than how Brendan played
it yet it completely worked for me back
then so it just shows you there's so
many different paths through Sam's
incredible words
foreign
she did not want me around you
hoped that she would change her mind
eventually but she's gonna just [ __ ]
called me
all this time
could have been a part of my life
really
who would want me to be a part of their
life
[Music]
I think it was apparent that that
authenticity and honesty about what we
were doing Lynn Credence to the
vulnerability it takes to tell the story
and the amount of trust we had with one
another I think is what brought that all
to life and so Darren didn't really
interfere in that way but like every
good director he would show you where it
is he would Point go over there that's
how you get there that's what a director
does
[Music]
thank you